hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today it's
actually raining outside right now
pretty hard so hopefully you can't hear
it too well so today let's solve an easy
question reverse a linked list and this
question is actually like a sub problem
that's needed in a lot of other
questions like linked list related
questions so it's definitely
good to understand so just like the
problem says we have a linked list
we've got some nodes and and we just
want to take
each of these links reverse them
keep doing that with everything and then
this is going to be the new head
and then we're going to return that
and they tell us that this can be done
two ways iteratively meaning with just
pointers
and also recursively and i'll show you
how to do it both ways
so we can do this with two pointers
because we want to reverse it so like
from the perspective of this node
instead of
the next pointer pointing at three we
want it to point at the previous
node one so if we want to do this
iteratively we can use two
pointers like many problems
now what are the two pointers going to
be we can have initially
a current pointer so we can initialize
current to the first node
which is our head and we can also
maintain
a previous pointer which initially
is going to be set to null
so for the first node 1 we're going to
take
the next pointer and reverse it so now
the next
pointer is going to be pointing at null
so this is now going to be the last
element in our new reversed linked list
so now we can shift our pointers
so we're going to take the previous
pointer and then shift it to current
and we're going to take the current
pointer and shift it
to the next node now since we broke this
link we have to save this somewhere
before we end up breaking this link and
i'm going to show you how to do that
in the code so now our current is 2
we want to take the next pointer
and reverse it so the next is now going
to be
like this so it's going to point at
previous
so we can reverse the next pointer and
set it to previous
and once again we're going to shift our
previous pointer to current and our
current pointer is going to be shifted
to next
now we're finally at the last node we
can once again
update the next pointer of this current
node and so
now when we update our pointers previous
will be here
and current is going to be at
null we've reached the end of our list
now we want to return the head
how do we return the head lucky for us
the previous pointer
is equal to the new head right so this
is going to be our result
just like in the drawing we can
initialize our pointers first
previous will initially be null current
will start
at the head and we want to keep going
until we reach
the end of the list so while current is
not null
we're going to reverse the pointers so
we want
current dot next to be set to
previous and then we can shift our
pointers right so we can update previous
set it to cur and
cur is going to be equal to current.next
but notice how we set current.next
to previous before so when we do this
we actually are going to have a
temporary variable
called next which i will do at the
first line when we start our loop so we
can save that in next
so then when we update current.next
you know we still have that next pointer
and lastly we return the result which we
know
is stored in previous when this loop
stops executing
so it works and this is actually the
most optimal solution the time
complexity is big o of n
and the memory complexity is big o of 1
because we're just using pointers right
no
data structures or anything but if we
want to do the recursive solution
then the time complexity is also going
to remain
linear but the memory complexity is
going to be
linear as well so we're going to need
extra memory so it's not the best
solution but i'll still show you how to
do it
so usually the best way to think about
recursive problems
is to break it down into a sub problem
right so
if our initial head is one
we start at one and this is our linked
list right
but let's say i want to do a recursive
call
instead of reversing the entire linked
list
i'm gonna reverse the remainder of the
linked list
so everything except this one
so now i have a sub problem right now i
only have
two nodes to deal with but let's take it
one step
further this is now my new head right
and i'm gonna break it down even more
i'm gonna say reverse
this portion reverse the sub problem
reverse only
one node so then if we try to break it
down even more then we're going to get
this is our sub list right but this is
just
null so we can't really reverse that
that's the base case
so now we're at this we only have one
node and we want to reverse
it how do we do that well the next
pointer is pointing at
null instead of that we can take the
next pointer
and set it to previous not really
because this is recursive
and at least the way i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna set
i'm gonna keep the pointer pointing at
null so we technically reversed this
portion which is
just this right it's just a link list of
one so now we're going to pop
back up out of our recursive call
and now our job is to reverse these two
nodes so since we're at
2 we can access three
so what i'm gonna do is say okay the
next pointer of this
is actually gonna be set to me to
is gonna be set to two where i'm at
right now
but my next pointer two's next pointer
is gonna be set to null
so notice that so far we have
done our job we reversed a linked list
of size two right this is going to be
the new head and this is the tail this
is the end of the list
so we did our job of reversing it
reversing these two nodes but we still
have one more node so we're going to
pop back up out of our recursive call
okay so now we're finally at the last
call so our sub problem
is to reverse these three nodes and we
can repeat the same thing we did over
here
we're gonna for one ins since one has
access to two
we're going to set two's next pointer
over here instead of
null we're going to set it to
one and the next pointer
of one is now going to be
null because we've reached the end
this is going to be the new end of our
linked list
so we've done our job we recursively
took our linked list and reversed it
the only problem is that we are doing
this recursively so
we have to in our code we're gonna have
to maintain
the last node as the new head
so now let's code it up as with most
recursive functions
you want to do the base case first so if
the head is
null we can return
null and i'm going to make a variable
to maintain the new head which i'm going
to initially set to head
head is the current node that we're at
in our recursive call so
if head dot next
is not null if there's still a sub
problem if we can keep
uh reversing then we're gonna have our
recursive call so
reverse the list
pass in head dot next and
the return value of this we are going to
have as the new head
so if this returns something
so we're going to set the result of that
to
new head and since head dot next
is the next node of head we want to
reverse that link so what we can do
is get the double
so head dot next dot next
is going to be set to head what this is
doing is just
reversing the link between the next node
and head
and lastly we can say head dot
next is going to be equal to null so if
head happens to be the first node in the
list
we're setting the next pointer to null
and
of course this function wants us to
reverse the list and return the new head
so
we're gonna return the new head
so i think so this works and i think it
might be a little confusing the way i
wrote it because we have head.next.next
but if you want to understand it a
little more
i would try to like mentally
run through a couple test cases for
example if you were just given one node
like
if you were just given a linked list of
this try to run through the code
see what the code does see what the
function returns see which like this
statement would not ever execute if we
were given
a link list of size one this is not
going to execute
so just kind of like try that out see
what happens if
you had a linked list of size two
like this and use pen and paper draw a
picture
and lastly the reason why the memory is
linear is because if we were given a
linked list
of size two our recursive call
is gonna be size two but i hope this was
helpful
please leave a like and subscribe thank
you and thank you so much for watching
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon